synonyme de chaos dans l'actualité
internationale
kaboul évoque la gastronomie afghane à
saint malo sahel et le gérant du
restaurant éponyme dans la bourgade
bretonne arrivé en france en 2009 avec
un statut de réfugié celui qui était
pharmacien de formation est reparti de
zéro lorsqu'il est arrivé dans
l'hexagone une partie de sa famille est
restée en afghanistan depuis la reprise
du pays par les talibans ça elle est
très inquiet tous les jours ils
l'appellent ses frères le premier vient
d'arriver en angleterre après avoir été
contraint à son tour de tout quitter
lorsque j'ai fut mon pays j'ai tout
laissé derrière moi ma maison ma voiture
mon argent
je suis juste partie de l'afghanistan
avec ce tee shirt parce que ma vie était
en danger
son deuxième frère est toujours à kaboul
obligé de se cacher ayant travaillé pour
le gouvernement et pour des médias
étrangers
en tant que techniciens et journalistes
producteurs il se dit rechercher par les
talibans
toutes les nuits les talibans qui
traquent ceux qui ont travaillé pour le
gouvernement ou pour des organisations
étrangères
nous sommes en danger et nous devons
souvent changé de position et de
logement il y a trois jours j'étais dans
un logement différent d'aujourd'hui afin
qu'ils ne me trouve pas
ça elle se démène depuis plusieurs
semaines pour le faire venir en france
sans succès pour l'instant je vais
démarche par les ministères affaires
étrangères j'ai envoyé plusieurs mails
ma famille d'accueil il envoyé plusieurs
mails j'ai n'est qu'une réponse par les
gouvernements en france la france
c'est très long on sort les
administratifs sur les migrants
désespérés ça elle affirme être prêt à
verser 100 mille euros pour que la
france rapatrie son frère tout en le
prenant totalement en charge sur le
territoire aujourd'hui ça elle n'a
qu'une crainte que l'afghanistan bascule
dans un conflit semblable à celui qu'a
connu la syrie et de ne jamais retrouver
son frère